منذ 13 عاما بدا الروهينغي الهجره بحرا
نحو سواحل اندونيسيا الغربيه تتفاوت
اعدادهم من سنه لاخرى فبعد انحسار لافت
خلال عامي الجائحه شهدت الاسابيع الاخيره
تزايدا في اعداد الفارينه من مخيمات
النازحين في بنغلاديش الى اندونيسيا هنا
سيطول مقامهم وقد يمتد لسنوات
اول ما يطلبه الناجون من رحله بحريه ملئها
المخاطره هو الاتصال بذويهم بطمئنتهم على
احوالهم
لا نسمع صوتك كيف حالكم اخبرنا ماذا حصل
معكم
هناك عاصفه ومطر غزير ونحن في السفينه وسط
البحر وقد مات كثيرون منا وكنا من الناجين
ووصلنا والحمد لله
اللافت ان الغالبيه منهم شباب واطفال
ونسوه خلافا لمن هاجر في سنوات سابقه حيث
كان عدد كبار السن اكثر عبد الشكور احد
هؤلاء يحلم بالهجره كسوه باخوه له سبقوه
قبل سنوات الى ماليزيا والولايات المتحده
احرقت منازلنا فعرضنا الى بنجلاديش حيث
مخيمات اللاجئين لكن لا تعليم ولا تحسن في
حياه اقتصاديا ولذلك فرغنا الى اندونيسيا
الحلو هنا احسن واهلها يرحبون بنا
خمسه اسابيع قضاها اللاجئون الرهنجيا على
متن هذه السفينه في رحله امتدت من خليج
البنغالي شمالا وعبر المحيط الهندي وصولا
الى هذه السواحل في اقليم اكشن اندونيسي
ضمن مسار بحري سلكه الاف من الروهينيا
خلال السنوات الماضيه ظاهره تطرح تساؤلات
جذريه عن هذه الرحله المحفوفه بالمخاطر
[موسيقى]
فالرحله البحريه من سواحل الحدود بين
بنغلاديش ومين مار تمر ببحر اندامان غربيه
تايلاند وتتجاوز غربيه ماليزيا الى مضيق
ملقه يدفع فيها اللاجئون لتجار الموت
مبالغ قد تتضاعف خلال الرحله
في مخيمات اللاجئين في كوكس بازار يفر
اللاجئون من الاضطهاد او الصراعات تاركين
اهليهم وراءهم بحثا عن مكان اكثر امنا
ويواجهون صعوبات ومخاطر خلال الرحله
الرحله يغرونهم بالرحيل لكنهم يواجهون خطر
الموت جوعا يعزو ناشطون ارتفاع اعداد
اللاجئين الى حاله الياس التي عصفت باكثر
من مليون نازح في مخيمات كوكس بازار في
بنغلاديش بعد ان فقدوا الامل في تحسن
احوالهم المعيشيه بدا اكبر مخيم للاجئين
في العالم يتشكل منذ موجه نزوح لروهينغا
في التسعينيات ثم تضاعف العدد اثر موجه
عنف ونزوح عام 2017
[تصفيق]
وتجمع عشرات الالاف منهم للمطالبه بتسويه
قضيتهم بضمانات دوليه تمهيدا لعودتهم الى
قراهم بعد ان ايقنوا ان الظفره بفرصه
للعيش بكرامه غايه لا تدركها الا قله منهم
صهيب جاسم الجزيره اقليم اتشي الاندونيسي